nicola sono senza parole di voi
nico i contanti di spirito totalmente 14
giorni difficilissimi e disperse dopo le
caronia 40 minuti napoli salerno a
50.000 timpa stilista impazzito say it
and roll e toney douglas in gol
io sono entrato qui dentro pensando il
city aveva presentato alla honda invece
paola tanta non respini da fumo tua
distribuita sentire in cordate stato
senza comunque la società in donata alla
grande dopo mi si è perché per colpa sua
è stata la volta giorni di merda e se
voglio fare pure c'è una picca compare
carica quando parlavo molto con lei
questa volta lo show down buoni da una
pazza comunque sono qui perché ti amo ti
ho deciso ecco tavola
e comunque questo genere sfida sarà a
bomb ballato come faib iraniano è
d'accordo siamo bene quando siamo andati
quasi le promesse e poi lo copi giorni
la vedo un virus a denis che proprio non
mi piace allora mo parlo io vivo giorno
per un video vede e farli rendere no
perché lui è cattivo e violento e vabbè
come un giorno delle balie mbriaca una
comuntà non parlare di giri intorno e
lasciamo meglio poi a firenze un video
mi dici di no perché io che mi capita
qualcuno vemente realtà ne frega niente
ad attrarre cinque anni ha spaccato
mezzo villaggio piatto per un'ora o
manette che le diciamo gli occhi fuori
dalle orbite a roma dove tradito cretino
ma il lavoro ancora vola subito la
superhit sinceramente non è vero un
video troppo aggressive lo più reattivo
e non è compito perché mai due palle
così per ogni cosa
le velate ma io che devo farlo per enti
purtroppo sta stronza
tutti erano lenti che mettendo per
strada aumenti che coltiviamo e non è
proprio un nome elenco ma le dita e
salvato quattro macchinosamente in crisi
e meno diversi da un matto cioè melo ma
tutte le commesse un gioco niente l'ho
convinto giorno riva questo ciò che dio
creò il pesce vincere dopo quinto giorno
mi son reso conto che facili laurea che
mi mancavi e nei bancari cantata al
furbo a marameo preso come quello che
volevo perdere è messo in gioco dopo
vincere e ho messo i puntini sulle i
pericoli diego maj detenuti il che il
fiume resta volete andare avanti voglia
di andare a comunque non meno merda
ciano voli su mito solamente le stringe
troppo leggero e così preoccupati di
quello che potevo credere nel weekend
non averti fatto niente di quello che ha
fatto capitolare presentato da che vale
o amelio tavolino due cose diverse e
dopo 5 anni voglia delle cose che tu mi
ha detto chiaramente che non mi puoi
dare a un tè voglio questi già parla
cosa che non vuoi fare ma temiamo gli
imperi video capitano mi poteva evitare
non faccio proprio letto vincerà la
moglie dell'altro grady me torna a casa
con meo fidare dei tiri li voglio per la
venticinquesima possibilità però
l'ultimo appunto cioè in mezzo ai
tentatori mi sono proprio distaccato
dalla realtà perché ho pensato di
potermi meritare qualcosa di più
ho pensato di poter militare umano con
azienda con dei salmi di me pare che un
futuro troppo quando poi tornata appunto
a casa li prendo tutti i commenti
negativi delle persone sul social e
capendo che mi ero fatta veramente la
figura di merda e ho detto cavolo
ma di principe artù metterò sempre avuta
bianco lo amo da morire ruben lube è
l'amore con la a maiuscola
un punto quello che si dice un punto
quello che si sente in rubando amo
vivere tutto per me è la mia vita
all'uomo da morire e il pollo e
ricordate di ragazze dove c'è coerente
se non c'è che un passion island alla
prossima stagione